[Musique]
pour son deuxième jour de visite à La
Réunion Jean-François caranco ministre
délégué chargé des Outre-mer s'est rendu
au département ce vendredi 17 février
dans la matinée pour rencontrer Cyril
Melchior le président de la collectivité
ainsi que ses vices présidents ont
échangé avec le ministre sur les
différents dossiers qui concernent le
territoire réunionnais
des compétences fortes il a même les
palkionne compétences agricole avec la
gestion du CADR donc on en a parlé on a
parlé de culture on a parlé de logements
on a parlé l'agriculture l'État se met
derrière ceux qui sont responsables la
chance d'avoir un responsable un vrai
donc lui est derrière lui c'est un
plaisir pour moi de recevoir le ministre
des Outre-mer bien évidemment nous avons
évoqué comme il a dit des sujets
d'importance capitale pour les
Réunionnais notamment de la politique de
logement aussi à la Réunion donc des
efforts de rattrapage en termes de
construction de réhabilitation des
logements nous avons parlé aussi de
formation puisque nous avons besoin de
former des cadres réunionnais pour
occuper des postes à responsabilité
notamment dans les la fonction publique
nous avons aussi parlé de l'agriculture
réunionnaise et des sujets qui vont être
au courant pour dès ce matin et bien
évidemment aussi la transition
écologique avec notre plan emblématique
de 1 million d'arbres l'État à travers
les fonds dédiés à la transition
écologique des crédits ouverts et bien
le département et la Réunion donc pourra
émerger bénéficier donc du soutien
financier de l'État donc ce sont des
sujets qui relèvent du social bien
évidemment mais aussi de l'aménagement
et de la transition écologique un
échange fructueux qui a permis au
ministre de mieux appréhender la
situation sociale des familles
réunionnaises la délégation a ensuite
pris la direction de la petite île sur
l'exploitation de Joël sores pour
échanger avec les agriculteurs de la
filière fruits et légumes les membres
des organisations professionnelles et
les représentants de la Chambre
d'Agriculture ceux qui sont en
difficulté de faire des évolutions du
pays notamment sur les entrants ce sont
les agriculteurs on ne laissera pas
tomber les agriculteurs c'est ça vu la
richesse potentielle de ce système on va
pas laisser tomber on n'attaquons pas
surtout tout de suite chez les problèmes
financiers attaquons sur
qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire comment on le
fait ensemble il y a beaucoup
d'interrogations autour des filières
fruits et légumes et les professionnels
s'interrogent par rapport aux
difficultés que chacun rencontre au
quotidien et il était important que le
ministre Vienne justement à la rencontre
des acteurs qu'elle soit les
agriculteurs les producteurs mais aussi
ceux qui ont structuré les différentes
filières d'école ici à la Réunion bien
évidemment nous sommes tous mobilisés
derrière nous agriculteurs parce que il
y a de la qualité il y a de la quantité
aussi mais il y a des difficultés par
rapport à la vie chère par rapport aux
difficultés de main d'oeuvre et bien
nous sommes là pour les accompagner et
le message du ministre en lien bien sûr
avec le département c'est que l'État et
le Conseil départemental sont résolument
mobilisés
pour faire de l'accompagnement pour les
agriculteurs une matinée qui s'est
achevée avec la visite de la syllabe où
s'est déroulée une rencontre avec les
acteurs de la filière lait et élevage
l'occasion de revenir sur les enjeux de
la souveraineté alimentaire sur les
plans de filière et sur le plan
d'autonomie alimentaire qui est en cours
d'élaboration
[Musique]